[Music]
[Music]
you stumbled upon an opportunity
I can make you rich rich enough to
impress a princess
what would I have to do there's a Cave
of Wonders
bring me the land
[Music]
oh great ones and summons me I stand by
my oath loyalty two wishes three I'm
kidding Russia's
[Music]
hey can you make me a prince there is
all out of gray area in make me a prince
I could just make you a prince oh no you
look like a prince on the outside but I
didn't change anything on the inside
Showtime no I'm in charge okay I say
when it's done
[Music]
really
I thought a princess could go anywhere
not this princess do you trust me
[Music]
you should see these places I mean
there's a whole world outside of books
and maps you wanted
how every door is guarded we said
anything about a door what are you doing
sometimes princess sometimes you just
have to take a risk
what just happened is this a magic
carpet
do you trust me
what did you say do you trust me
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
Prince Ali show some respect
boy can you flip down a onesie
now try your best to stay calm Russia
Friday salon then come and meet a
spectacular goal during Holi
[Music]
long as ten breaking amendment
definitely
he's based a galloping horse a hundred
bad guys with swords
[Music]
hey can you make me a prince there is a
lot of gray area in make me a prince I
could just make you a prince oh no right
you'd be snuggled up with that dude for
the rest of your life
be specific with your words the deal is
in the detail got it which I don't
really understand because if she already
likes you why change I told you she test
marry a prince
okay I can do that sure tea how did you
get past the guards that was challenging
you cannot just break into a palace like
you own the place
if you don't have anything you have to
act like you own everything use someone
upon an opportunity
I can make you rich rich enough to
impress a princess what would I have to
do there's a Cave of Wonders
bring me the land
oh great one who summons me I stand by
my oath loyalty two wishes three I'm
kidding Rustin do you trust me
whatare do we need the topknot that's my
little cherry on top rated PG Aladdin is
just one of those stories
they just burrows down inside of you you
don't know how you know every word of
the songs you just do Aladdin obviously
a Disney classic it was fun it was
adventurous
how are you trouble only if you get
caught we're trying to stay truthful to
the original but we also wanted to give
people something different and what's
awesome is Alan Menken the genius behind
the classic songs Disney enlisted him on
this movie as well
people are gonna breathe fall in love
with this incredible music
it really was an extravaganza
you know Showtime as actors we felt
comfortable and confident to take shots
you really don't know who I am you get
to just have wild fun well bust through
the screen is funny that's your personal
business he's charismatic he's amazing
you can clap now a handsome prince wants
to marry you
Oh what will life get easier we have a
new character in this film Dahlia I play
Dahlia Jasmine's best friend Naomi and I
immediately hit it off I mean we had so
much fun we would just cry laughing in
between takes he's just fun on set you
know there's very few films that have
singing dancing drama comedy like all of
those elements I love coming to work
every day
you ain't never had a friend like me one
of the things that I love about Aladdin
is that it's a fairy tale story in
another part of the world in this world
of Agrabah in making this movie we
wanted to make sure we're as authentic
as possible so ultimately we decided to
go out and to shoot on location we shot
out in Jordan the place called Wadi Rum
you can just feel the history in the
sand I think it adds a level of reality
trouble only if you get caught in
creating Agrabah we wanted to get the
balance just right so we had a team of
culture advisors in order to give it an
authentic voice are more than our robots
truly a global trading port heavily
influenced by Arabia but also influenced
by other neighboring cultures as well
Jemma Jackson our production designer
and her crews did an amazing job I mean
the whole term Middle East is sort of my
favorite place I think probably doing
Game of Thrones open the whole door up I
started having to look much further
around the world for inspiration
baklava so I just had an absolute ball
building Agrabah you know stepping on to
set the first time it was it was insane
when we see they actually built this
whole city
it really was magical you could
genuinely get lost in the streets it was
really really important to Agrabah
feel like the real location
it's just so visually stunning and the
palace and Jasmine's room the throne
room just took my breath away from the
costumes to the sets it was unlike
anything I've ever seen
I'm excited to sit in an audience to see
it because everyone really doubled and
tripled down on getting it right and now
a special look at Disney's Aladdin who's
the girl
she's a princess Oh aren't they all oh
we've had a connection but she has to
marry a prince back up where I need some
room to work
I made you to look like a prince on the
outside but I didn't change anything on
the inside
Prince Ali got you to the door do you
trust me what did you say but Aladdin
has to open it do you trust me
[Music]
[Music]
sometimes princess you just have to take
a risk
rated PG I play the genie than Aladdin
what did I do to prepare for the role
you know I spent about six weeks in a
lamp
[Music]
part of what I connected to with this
movie is the concepts around friendship
who's the girl
she's a princess Oh aren't they all
ideas around love around self-worth I'm
excited to be a part of talking about
that in the world you have got to be
more confident about what you have to
offer the genies trying to teach Aladdin
to be comfortable with who he is do you
trust me very similar to what I'm trying
to teach my kids to be empowered to be
who you are
Aladdin is a spectacular family film it
has drama
it has comedy everybody can enjoy this
movie sometimes you just have to take a
risk
rated PG
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
buzz for with
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]